so we have a Matt Walsh video coming up
and he said it would be great if we
could go one day without a woman on
social media promoting shallowness and
selfless selfishness as a path to Joy
and fulfillment so it seems that a lot
of ladies are getting divorced before
they turn 30. and as someone who got
married at 26 has been separated for a
little over a year 32 I have to tell you
I don't think there's anything better if
being in your 20s with the trenches
there is nothing better than being in
your 30s still being hot maybe having a
little bit of your own money figuring
out what you want to do with your life
everything and having tried that married
fantasy and realizing that it's maybe
not all it's cracked up to be and then
you've got your whole life still ahead
of you